[Music]
let's go out to claire in cincinnati
what's up claire how are we doing
doing good how are you we are having a
blast what's up
so dr john i have a situation with a
couple questions for you anytime
somebody starts a sentence with
so
then i always have to hang on to the
desk a little bit all right so what's
going
on so all right again
um
my whole life i've had this narrative
for my mother
that my father um
is her ex-husband
who has you know he passed away
she told me some
so great things about him too that he
was workaholic he was abusive so that
was kind of the narrative that i had
um and then flash forward to
20 something years later
my husband was at work and he got
a call from a stranger
he was asking questions about my father
and it turns out he is claiming to be my
father
yeah yeah offered like a dna test and so
i i'm taking it pretty
pretty seriously yeah so he he offered
to take a dna test or he offered to show
i mean
how do you know this isn't just some
creep of the week
person
i think
because of how my mother is
it would it would make sense
have you talked to your mom about
this no
it's very hard to approach her with
things
why
um
i'm a pretty sensitive person i don't
like confrontation
and she is
narcissist is a very strong word but
there are a lot of tendencies that i've
seen
so it's kind of a bullying like no
responsibilities ever taken it's
switched back on me
so my fear is if i go to her with this
i'm just going to be blamed somehow
um
and my trust has already been pretty
violated so i don't really want that on
top of it
so
here
tell me if i'm off okay
it feels like somebody came out of the
blue
and told you some things is he giving
you some like convincing this is or that
or is he just
telling you hey i'm willing to take a
dna test i'm pretty sure i'm your dad i
look like you like we have same color
hair i mean what's he telling you to
convince you
so i haven't actually spoken to him yet
he called
this is kind of a red flag to me he did
he called my husband not me
so i haven't actually spoken to him yet
okay so
here's what
[Applause]
man
here's what i wanted you to be careful
of
your mom told you your dad passed away
when you were young is that right
okay
there's a part of you
that really hopes that's not true
and what kind of story would it be if
all along your dad was alive and you
found him and
sounds like you've had some challenges
with your mom over the years some heavy
stuff some hard stuff
and to the point that you don't even
want to ask her is there a chance that
her story so
the idea
this
person could come and really fill a hole
that you have a mom and dad's size hole
that the the appeal of that story just
from me as a listener who just met you
like a minute and a half ago dude i want
that to be the case in your life
and i want him to come out and be like
she told me you had passed away and here
i am and all the story and
i want that to be the case
we are way way far away from that
right now you've got some dude who
reached out to your husband
maybe from your mom's past and is
throwing a story out
so one of two things happens if i'm you
number one i'm going directly to my mom
and saying i am scheduling a dna test
with a man who claims to be my father
is this possible before i go through
this not hey what do you think but i'm a
grown woman who can do whatever i want
to and i'm about to do this
do you have anything you want to tell me
that's probably the track i would take
and i know you don't like
confrontationalists this confrontation
has found you not the other way around
okay either you are faced with a
26 27 year old lie
and you've been robbed of of your entire
life of having your father in there in
your life
or
you have a psychotic crazy person trying
to get into your life trying to weasel
their way yeah you hear what i'm saying
yeah and it feels like the story here
and your soul has spun up much faster
than the data that you're working with
the other side is have you
i mean this guy want to meet you does he
want to talk to you
he does um
so when he spoke to my husband he was
kind of
my husband was saying you know we're
gonna need to sit on this for a little
bit contact will not be
direct um
so yeah he he knows like it'll take a
couple
couple months here to like reach out or
initiate anything and so what what is
going to happen in that couple of months
like what are you going to just sit and
think on besides just making yourself
crazy
well i'm also pregnant and i'll be
giving birth here soon so that was kind
of
my main priority and i think
i just want to protect the family that i
have already i don't really want to
introduce this new guy if he's not worth
my time or if he is crazy because that
was something i thought about too you
know like this random guy like now i'm
having a child and you want to be in my
life it just
it did feel a little bit weird
the whole thing feels weird
what i don't want you to do is allow the
weird to come to you i want you to meet
the weird head-on
and you sounds like you have a great
husband with you
maybe you offer um i don't know if they
would do this in your area i know some
places would
that you reach out to the non-emergency
police department in your area or the
fire department in your area and say a
man has come out claiming to be my
father and i want to do dna tests would
it be possible for us to do it there
where there is safety
and um or possibly at a local hospital
um or i just had some blood work done a
follow-up i'm just doing a bunch of
blood work for my doctor and i went to a
place and they said that they do
paternity tests and all kinds of things
there all of the time and they can
schedule them
um in staggered pla we were i got to
talking with the phlebotomist and it was
she was fascinating man she she sees
some stuff but she's seen um paternity
tests like people get fistfights there
she's had people come in and do
paternity tests and then leave and then
the next person comes in
and and then she calls both of them back
or emails both of them back with this
you know you are not the father you are
that kind of thing
i think you can set that up
and or you can go to the local
phlebotomist which is just like one of
those you know any lab test now kind of
places and they're on street corners
everywhere you could go in actually do
your test and then have your husband
contact this person and say i've done
she's done her part of the test you need
to go to this place and have it done and
then the test results will be sent to
her
you can do that and then you never have
to talk to him see him and if this
person's interested in being in your
life they can go get the test done
without ever having to interact with you
so here's what i'm saying there's a
couple of different things
here's what i don't want you to do
if there's nothing like you're not going
to have
you're not going to talk to people
you're not going to chase down all bros
and sisters you're not going to call
your mom you're not gonna do these
things so waiting two months
to wrap this up
is gonna make you and your brand new
baby nuts
not really your brand new baby i kind of
just threw that in for a fact but it's
gonna make you and your husband bonkers
yeah i'd much rather you see you just go
meet this fine i'm gonna go get my test
today
and dude you've got 48 hours you're my
dad and you're about to be a grandfather
you got 48 hours
like i would approach it that way
and i'm taking control of this
here if you hear nothing else hear this
you don't like conflict and conflict has
found you
okay great and so i i would in fact if
i'm you i'm i'm retracting what i said
earlier i'd be on the phone with
everybody i would schedule that dna test
in a staggered thing either at a police
department in a non-emergency police
department or at a local shop i'd go
ahead and do mine and be gone and then
tell him he's got 48 hours to come do it
there and i would call my mom i'd call
everybody i would turn all the lights on
and be like so some guy's coming out is
this right because the blood test is
already on the way mom what do you got
to tell me i would do it like that
and if she says you're crazy nothing
this never happened like cool well the
test is going to find out because this
is bananas
and dude
call me back if you come to find out
that your dad was really alive all this
time
because now you're in a whole other
adventure right
yeah that's kind of what also is
stressing me out too i think maybe
that's the whole idea of oh i'm gonna
wait these couple months because i just
don't know how to deal with it um
because and then the other crazier part
i don't know if i mentioned this but
he's
been in this in a city where
you know like i was living my whole
childhood he was there that's what he
told my husband so there's lots of
there's lots of stories about
um
strange arrangements early on someone
might have struggled with alcohol drug
addiction somebody might have struggled
with
um any number of things and there's a
handshake agreement between a mom and a
dad saying
i'll step out of their life
but they watch their life from afar i've
seen some really heartbreaking stories
where
moms or dads out of the picture who've
been told hey your mom and dad died have
these real elaborate like uh photo
albums of school clippings and things
like that that they just watched their
kid grow up they just went in their life
and so that i mean that didn't surprise
me at all not even a little bit but
they're me who knows what the story was
26 years ago
who knows what the story was right
um and whatever story you get will
probably mostly the truth-ish
right
um
maybe so i don't know so before we
before i let you go
i don't know what to root for here
whether i don't know either desperately
want your dad to be alive and you to
have the other 75 years of your life
with him
or or he won't be 70 50 more years with
him and you all figured that out
or and find out your mom lied to you
just stole from you or
um
that i want this thing to be put to be
put to rest
which one do you want
it's hard to say for me too i think
in an ideal world i could have both of
those relationships but something tells
me
um
it's gonna be
either
one you know my mom or my dad or none of
them um
because these are
i know how my mother is just very um
extreme so gotcha it would take a while
to rebuild yeah so here's a beautiful
moment you're about to have is this your
first baby
yes girl or boy
a boy all right so you're about to and i
would have said all right if it was a
girl too i'm just trying to be
supportive um
you and your husband and now your new
son
this family is y'alls
so nobody else gets a vote
not your mom not your this person coming
out of the woodwork nobody you all too
you all decide who else gets to speak
into your life and what i'd love for you
and your husband to do before you get
the blood test before you start making
the calls which i hope you do today i
hope you start today and you're like you
know what forget everybody this is mine
right i hope that's your attitude
but i want you and your husband to come
up with the boundaries
i'll talk to mom once a day
i will answer mom's text once a day
regardless of what happens
i will
invite this man to dinner one time
until we and then i will then regroup
from there i want y'all to set some
boundaries
so that when whatever happens happens
you don't immediately get dragged
underwater
that you're like whoa mom lied to me for
25 years all right we've already etched
in stone here i'm only gonna talk to her
once a day
so i'm gonna text her and say mom i got
the paternity test back this man is my
father
this is very hard for me right now i
will be in touch
and then i'm not answering the phone
after that i'm not answering text
messages because i am in control these
are my boundaries these are me and my
husband's boundaries hear what i'm
saying
for
26 years claire you've lived under this
thumb this thumb
and today it comes off yeah hear what
i'm saying
yes i'm ready for that today you become
freaking claire
and the thumb comes off
ready right let's go let's go say thank
you
yes
today is the day
that claire says no this is mine this is
my life
it's my life cue bon jovi right now
which would have been epic you missed
that one then it's cool though
we cube on jovi it's your life it's time
to stand up boundaries for you
hey let me know cause i want to know how
this one ends